[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver une nouvelle
fois sur cette chaîne aujourd'hui on va
parler de cinq accessoires que j'utilise
pour mes vidéos que ce soit pour youtube
ou pour d'autres projets à côté vous
allez voir que ça va être vachement
intéressante parce qu'à des trucs qui
peuvent vous faire gagner beaucoup de
temps et qui sont super pratique et en
plus de ça je vous mettrai tous les
liens vers ses articles là dans la
description
ouais je suis mes coups je sais alors
l'idée bien sûr c'est pas de vous faire
une région produit en mode télé achat ce
sont des trucs que je kiffe pas plus que
ça c'est surtout de vous donner mon
retour d'expérience et de vous montrer
un petit peu ce qu'on peut faire avec
ces objets là c'est pas de la récitation
de fiche technique on est bien d'accord
c'est vraiment du bénin dans le cambouis
et du pratico pratique et l'idée avec
ses cinq accessoires ça va être soit de
gagner en efficacité de 28 ans tout
simplement quelque chose de plus
pratique
ou alors de gagner en qualité d'image
l'aspect un peu plus professionnel
il semble que d'attendre on va commencer
avec le tout premier c'est-à-dire le
monopole et pour la petite histoire vous
pouvez vous prendre pour gandalf avec et
c'est juste cool en mode
alors le monopole c'est un accessoire
que j'apprécie énormément parce qu'il
est beaucoup plus facile à trimballer
qu'un trépied quand on doit bouger lors
d'un tournage on n'a pas besoin de le
replier ou alors juste le bras
télescopique et encore on peut se
trimballer avec c'est vachement plus
pratique ça permet d'avoir des plantes
plus stable forcément pour du face
caméra comme ça sur youtube c'est pas du
tout intéressant parce que ça qu'ils
n'ont pas tout seul voeu qui n'a qu'un
pied mais ça va quand même vous
permettre d'avoir des trucs pas très
proche du trépied si vous filmez avec
plus de mobilité la plupart du temps
vous allez pouvoir faire des mouvements
de caméra qui vont être vachement sympa
moi j'ai opté pour le monopole basique
de chez amazon qui coûte que dalle plus
une rotule qui est une une copie on va
dire de recul manfrotto qui est
vachement bien foutu quasiment pareil
que sur du manfrotto pour deux ou trois
fois moins cher donc pas gêner les liens
dans la description vraiment c'est
plutôt cool surtout vraiment pour ses
mouvements de caméra qui vont pouvoir
être sympa comme tout le monde cela on
va surtout retrouver plus de liberté
qu'avec un stabilisateur par exemple on
va pouvoir avoir des mouvements un peu
plus un peu plus bizarre un peu plus
originaux on va dire qu'avec le
stabilisateur
alors il existe chez manfrotto un
monopole qui est vraiment vraiment sympa
mais qui coûte un petit peu cher quand
même pour ce que c'est moi je vous
conseille franchement ste config là qui
est beaucoup plus abordable que du
manfrotto et qui marche tout aussi bien
et puis est ce petit support là mais on
va en parler un petit peu après ça c'est
cool si c'est très très cool deuxième
accessoires qui coûtent pas franchement
super cher et qui va pouvoir donner un
gros plus aux vidéos qu'on va faire
c'est le slider là et là le slider comme
ça alors le spyder comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est un petit plateau ici sur
débarras ici en carbone je pense qu'il
va pouvoir se déplacer comme ça pour
faire des mouvements de caméra des
travellings tout simplement est ce petit
slides schnyder et ce petit slider de
chez newegg franchement
pour le prix je crois qu'il coûte dans
les 80 euros il m'a vachement surpris
parce que j'en avais essayé des sliders
à pas cher a été vachement déçu quand
même sur plein de trucs ça c'était
bancal ça c'était pas terrible c'était
lourd c'est pas pratique
celui-là il fait 80 cm il ya une version
je crois un peu plus petit 60 cm qui est
moins cher
et franchement c'est super fluide ça
marche super bien on peut faire des
plans vraiment un peu cinéma avec des
jolis mouvements sans trop se casser la
tête et sans avoir des tonnes de matos
il ya une fixation ici un plateau pour
mettre sur sur un trépied aussi
équipiers ici davis qui s'orientent qui
vont nous permettre de poser le bouzin
par terre sans avoir forcément non plus
besoin de le mettre sur un trépied si on
va faire un ras de sol ou sur une table
ou des choses comme ça donc vraiment ça
encore une fois ça coûte pas super cher
et ça peut permettre de varier les plans
et d'avoir ce petit bouquin petit peu
plus pro que vous retrouverez pas avec
juste un mouvement de caméra à la main
qui va forcément être un petit peu
tremblotant même si on peut stabiliser
derrière et c'est là vous allez avoir un
truc qui va vous permettre d'être encore
plus créatifs
le troisième accessoires ben je le porte
sur moi vous avez été des dizaines à me
poser la question depuis super longtemps
et à chaque fois je vous dis je vais
faire une vidéo dessus je vais faire une
vidéo sur une vidéo dessus c'est le
micro ici que j'ai juste là alors vous
me demandiez quelle était la référence
de mon micro cravate eh bien ce n'est
pas un micro cravate c'est tout
simplement un dictaphone de chez sony
je vous mets dans la description le lien
vers la référence exacte c'est un tout
petit dictaphone qui peut s'accrocher au
col ou dans une poche de chemise qui est
vraiment hyper pratique pour plusieurs
raisons déjà avec toutes les
configurations micro que j'avais essayé
quel que soit l'endroit où j'ai posé
j'avais un écho ça on le dira jamais
assez mais
le son il est aussi important que
l'image avec un sont dégueulasses comme
si je le prend par exemple le son du
boîtier ici directement avec un sont
dégueulasses on aura une vidéo
dégueulasse que ce soit l'image ou leçon
il faut accorder autant d'importance à
l'un comme à l'autre donc déjà j'ai
éliminé cet écho dans un premier temps
l'autre point intéressant c'est qu'il va
capter vraiment que la voix est éliminée
aussi en plus de l'éco tous les bruits
ambiants chez moi ça va il n'y a pas de
souci mais en extérieur abbas il ya
beaucoup de monde autour s'il ya des
travaux des choses comme ça avait pu le
voir quand j'utilise mon micro canon
quand je vais vous loguez dès qu'il ya
du bruit autour ça les captent l'aï si
vraiment on à l'umih ne veut pas dire
tous les bruits parasites mais une
grande quantité si ce n'est la majeure
partie des bruits qui sont autour et ça
c'est un plus non négligeable c'est
vraiment super content par contre petit
bémol sur ce micro enfin sur ce
dictaphone il a une tonalité de son très
très très médium c'est à dire que la
première fois que je vais utiliser je me
suis dit bordel de merde qu'est ce que
c'est que cette blouse parce que c'était
c'était vraiment inutilisable à jouer
par exemple le son brut sans retouche du
micro abbas c'est pas folichon donc il
faut faire un petit peu d'écho alisation
je me suis fait un petit précède que
j'applique systématiquement directement
dessus ça prend 30 secondes
il n'y a pas de souci mais il faudra
garder en tête qu'il faudra quand même
faire une petite correction au niveau de
l'égalisation pour le sens qu'ils
puissent est pas relié par un fil donc
ce qui me permet de parler un petit peu
partout à n'importe quelle distance de
la caméra sans avoir de problèmes de son
il faudra penser à importer les fichiers
du mp3 du dictaphone et les synchroniser
avec l'image sur votre logiciel de
montage et je vous mets juste ici une
vidéo d'un abonné qui a fait une super
vidéo de dirt vue technique justement
sur ce micro en détaillant toutes les
caractéristiques etc est allé la voir
franchement elle est sympa et ça donnera
encore plus de détails moi je fais du
pratico pratique on m'a dit voilà pour
le plus de détails ici quatrième
accessoires qui est juste indispensable
pour moi c'est le moniteur par le
moniteur jeu le fixe au dessus de ma
caméra ça va tout simplement me servir
de retour pouvoir voir un petit peu
faire mon cadrage quand je me film parce
que sur le gh5 sur le et auxerre
sur le 6 des surgelés s'est plu voilà
quasiment toutes les caméras maintenant
on retrouve d écran orientable qui se
retourne et sur lesquels on peut se voir
mais pas sur le sony à 7,3 pourquoi
pourquoi sony pourquoi vous l'avez pas
fait mais au delà de ça c'est vrai que
même en ayant un écran qui se retourne
ça reste un tout petit écran là j'ai un
moniteur qui est un petit peu plus grand
ses fils world la marque qui me
l'envoyer pour le tester et je remercie
au passage six moniteurs il est vraiment
très sympa mais au-delà de ça je vais
pas m'en servir que dans cet objectif de
me filmer mois pour avoir un retour par
exemple en extérieur sur des scènes qui
sont très éclairé souvent sur l'écran on
voit pas grand chose et le fait d'avoir
ce moniteur qui est quand même assez
lumineux et le petit cache le petit la
petite visière qui permet aussi de
mettre un petit peu de dons pour avoir
ce qu'on fait pour gérer l'exposition et
la composition c'est quand même
vachement pratique et on retrouve aussi
sur son moniteur mais sur la plupart des
moniteurs aussi on retrouve le focus à 6
le focus assiste le focus assist qui va
vous permettre grâce à des lignes rouges
de vous montrer ce qui est net et ce qui
ne l'est pas dans votre image donc si on
filme en manuel bas ça va quand même
être assez utile surtout si on fait avec
une grande ouverture mois pourra
vraiment si on est bien focus si tout
est bien comme il faut et il ya aussi la
possibilité d'utiliser les zébras pour
voir si on a des zones qui sont cramés
des zones qui sont mal exposés on va
pouvoir avoir tout ça grâce aux
moniteurs et celui-là le fil wap
franchement il n'est pas ou s'il ya des
moniteurs qui permettent d'enregistrer
carrément le signal etc
c'est double entrée de gamme on va dire
ça fait le job et franchement j'en suis
très content enfin le dernier accessoire
qui est selon moi le plus malin de tous
et en plus qui est le moins cher
il se trouve dans ma main et ben c'est
ça alors c'est ce que j'appelle moi
lévis magique en fait ce truc là
si vous avez pu voir au début sur le
monopole ou même sur ce trépied là où
sur mon stabilisateur sur le zim crane
j'utilise des plateaux comme ça pour
venir se fixer donc ce plateau se fixe
sous l'appareil et on vient l'enclencher
ici dans le
logements prévus à cet effet et ce sont
des plateaux qui sont standard donc ça
veut dire que sur mes deux caméras j'ai
toujours les plateaux qui sont vissés
quasiment en permanence comme ça ben
j'ai pas besoin de vie c'est quoi que ce
soit quand je veux le passé sur un
trépied un monopole ce qu'on veut je
glisse claque je sers terminé on n'en
parle plus le truc c'est que ça se visse
avec des petites vis comme ça qui est
généralement n'ont pas cette petite art
sicile
donc on a juste la fin de ce pouvoir vie
c est le banc le ca reste une vis donc
au bout d'un moment ça a tendance un
petit peu avec le jeu à se dévisser et
il faut sortir le plateau sortir une
petite pièce de 2 ou 5 centimes pour
bien resserré et la pièce moi je n'ai
pas toujours sur moi j'en ai souvent une
dans la poche au cas où mais ben non je
sais c'est chiant il faut sortir un truc
aller chercher son portefeuille enfin
sur un shooting c'est juste pas possible
et cette petite once ici là qu'on a là
bas on m'a tout simplement l'attraper
pour venir serrer à mort la vie c'est
l'art bloquée et ça c'est con mais c'est
un gain de temps monumental
on sort le plateau rac en met un petit
coup de vis est terminée on parle plus
et ça coûte ça coûte rien je sais même
pas c'est même pas un euro ces trucs là
donc monsieur par sac ce que je les
perds moins franchement c'est c'est
excellent c'est juste excellent le mec
qui a pensé à ça c'est un type qui avait
plus de pièces de 2 centimes dans sa
poche
il y en a eu aucun élu ras le cul qui se
retrouve un jour emmerder et du coup il
a inventé ça et je lui dis merci tu pas
qui c'est mais je lui dis merci
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas comme d'habitude à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous avez
d'autres astuces que vous utilisez des
petits accessoires qui vous simplifie la
vie n'hésitez pas à les mettre dans les
commentaires penser à partager cette
vidéo un maximum autour de vous la
chaîne a dépassé les dix sept mille
abonnés plus vachement cool même si j'ai
un peu de mal à tenir le rythme encore
plus que d'habitude pour faire des
vidéos régulièrement mais j'ai travaillé
je me soigne et je voulais remercier
particulièrement les types heures et les
gens qui vont sur your type qui
soutiennent la chaîne financièrement
c'est vachement vachement sympa de votre
part 2
de me remercier de donner cette valeur à
au vidéo que je vous donne vous avez les
liens youtube ça coûte rien il ya juste
une pub à regarder c'est juste en
dessous ou tipi aussi si vous voulez
faire un don et puis et puis voilà et
puis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux très très très très
curieux et puis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo vous ne passerez pas
l'udc
je suis pas le monopole c'est aussi des
heures d'amusement et de n'importe quoi
opium dire ce qu'ils aient le monopole
c'est ça aussi
voilà